hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to the
fresh and fit podcast um i think it was
labeled abba and preach
like was a guest and it was like versus
10 girls one of my subscribers actually
commented
that they wanted me to react to it so if
you have something that you want me to
react to
do not forget to comment it below also
do not forget to follow my instagram i
often do polls on there for what i
should react to next
so if you want to be involved in that
process follow my instagram which is in
the description below
okay um
sorry guys sometimes i get
a little nervous when i do these i don't
know why
okay so i'm gonna be like skipping
through it because this thing is
two hours long and you will not catch me
dead watching something for two hours
um what do ladies look for short term
versus long term
relationship so short-term
i would say obviously he has to be
attractive i definitely want somebody
attractive
um he has to be a good listener and he
also has to have a business
mindset um that's short term just
because that's basically what i'm very
passionate about and what i like to hold
conversations about
long term very similar um definitely
independent very ambitious
driven um and valuable i definitely
look for value i bring value so i expect
value
okay pretty good answer right okay
um short term good sex
and fun um obviously whatever he do
does with his life it's on on his own
you know i don't
have any expectations whatsoever i like
somebody who is like independent
and and believes in himself you know
likes being here in this world and
long-term
good sex
[Laughter]
and um somebody that would reinvent
himself
as well you know okay just one comment
i don't think sex is a make or break for
a long-term partner
like if you're gonna be married forever
you can
get better at stuff like you literally
have the rest of your lives to figure it
out
is that like a deal breaker for people
because i'm constantly changing so i
expect somebody to accept that
and to also be changing as well so if we
can both share that why not
wonderful yeah i'll come back on later
on in the show
all right all right short term um
obviously
we have to be attracted to each other um
i want some attention
and i want it to be fun so that
we can click and long term
someone who has goals whose who's on
that growth mindset as well
very very about that and who understands
or is willing to listen in on my
spiritual craziness
[Laughter]
well if it's short term definitely
physical part plays a role there has to
be some type of chemistry
and i'm really surprised by the number
of girls that talk about
physical stuff that's super important to
them
because i mean i get that when you're
like super young
you might think that but i feel like as
you grow and mature you start to realize
that
different things are more important like
values
common interests and conversation
i like to engage in like intellectual
conversation
and then if it's long-term definitely
there he has to have a certain
level of masculine maturity
and a well-integrated man morally
ethically and even when it comes to
family would you consider yourself a
sociosexual yes definitely awesome
all right yeah okay so
is sapiosexual that's when you're like
connect with people
intellectually right i don't understand
how that's a sexuality short term
obviously you have to be attractive um
and i like a lot of attention
so that's a big thing for me so you have
to give me the attention that i want
um long term i look for ambition
i look for drive you have to be able to
grow with me
and put up with my emotions because i am
a cancer
oh geez i hate it when girls
blame the way they act on their zodiac
side
look at i'm the worst zodiac sign i i
don't
follow that stuff but everyone tells me
scorpios are the worst
if i act bad i'm not gonna blame it on
my zodiac sign
let me just say you know [ __ ] i got work
to do you know
here we go so i don't ask for much
i just short term or good time that's it
bring it on and long-term um
long-term just family guy
loyal respectful and yeah a good time
hold on what does a good thing mean
though
i heard great sex because i mean that's
good yes of course okay
be attracted to each other and just good
chemistry and a good time good attitude
i'll tell you what good time means to
like for me it's somebody that you can
just be quiet with
like you don't have to talk all the time
being like i need your attention
and hey you need my attention no it's
like there we can just
enjoy a good time quiet beside each
other and doesn't mean like we're not
interacting it's just like ah this feels
good
okay so good feels all right over on the
culture
exactly go ahead short term i would
think
definitely somebody i'm attracted to
that's a big part of it uh somebody i
could
just have a good conversation with
long term i would like to say somebody
who's hardworking
is into anime for sure
and likes to have a fun time enjoy life
educated a little bit of everything wait
are you wearing a naruto
inspired shirt right now of course show
it off oh there you go that is awesome
man that's awesome okay cool
so for short term it's definitely
someone that can keep me like on my toes
that is spontaneous um that can like
give me some kind of like for sure
spontaneous
you know what i mean so when i curls
your toes someone that grows my toes
you're sure
and for long term it's someone that's
like someone that can feel like home for
me
like someone that i can be myself with
um
obviously like someone has like
long-term goals
um you know just like someone that i can
um i can feel like is my my best friend
like not just
a lover and a husband or whatever with
someone that i can
feel like i'm living like every single
day with and like
like i don't even okay so that for short
term and adventure gotta have fun gotta
be like playful
um long term exact same things
the money the muscles well yeah you've
got to be attractive so
that um adventurous
and they just want like the perfect guy
you've got to have like
those bass like morals values principles
things that you stand for need to be
similar to mine
so loyalty open communication um
yeah communication you said that i
really like that one transparency
yeah money huh so you know yeah
i didn't hear anyone else say that
ladies you're all lying everyone else
wants money come on you know you won't
want it
it's funny because everyone mentioned
these uh
extreme externals but nothing that's
going to be tangible like money so you
know anyone that said that
yeah now just uh i guess uh viewers just
watch and take notes guys
women are going to give you the
politically correct answer of what
they're attracted to
and what they want i want to ask
something i want to ask some of the
ladies ladies
who here would marry an ugly [ __ ] how
much money does he have
fun fact if you ever listen to jordan
peterson at all he talks about how it's
not about
money it's actually about usefulness
so women aren't necessarily attracted to
money by itself because if someone wins
the lottery that doesn't
make them more attractive um it's
usefulness
so like learning things the ability to
like
you know fix a car that's attractive the
ability to like
help you out with something that's
attractive oh seriously who here would
marry an ugly man
i would but it all depends on like it
depends on what ugly is
ugly
i feel like you can find someone not
that attractive at first and then
find them attractive later if they're
like
have the qualities and they're like a
nice person i'm talking about like if
you had an
honest scale of one to ten this man's
like a three
hmm that's a three for you but might not
be a three for her
he's short he's fat you know what i mean
it depends on your life
[ __ ] up face he has a huge
humor
okay this is what we'll do we'll start
with the couch we'll say yes or no uh
we'll start rocio and then go across
would you marry an ugly guy if his money
was right
i would say no because i want beautiful
children
okay okay all right keeping that bug um
honestly i find ugly guys attractive
uh so i don't know why i do find medium
ugly guys attractive
oh okay that looks like a chance all
right um so yeah probably
okay this is a yes or no um
yes yes this is yes or no gotta
i would honestly have to say
yes yeah you would yeah it depends no
you would not marry an ugly guy if his
money was right no short fat okay no
all right okay
me no no no
again if i would have liked that i would
have been there already so no
okay chris
spiritual girl we have to be connected
so probably not because i have good
taste
[Laughter]
no i think i could do better okay okay
so i'm gonna have to say no very
interesting everyone was saying yes
earlier
okay go ahead okay no no so okay just
beep something super fascinating you
gave objects for short term long term
short term they're like gotta be
attractive gotta [ __ ] right long term
they went into all this esoteric stuff
about
personality character i'm like cool
would you marry a ugly guy no
so it comes down to the fact that the
same thing they're looking for short
term you find out even in long-term
partners if they don't get it they're
not gonna be down
so i just thought that was interesting
that you guys all made it sound like
your short-term and long-term answers
different so much
but then when you were asked would you
marry an ugly man the looks came back
right away
well i wouldn't i don't agree with you
because again what is ugly to you
maybe my boyfriend right now is ugly to
everybody but he
he's got something that i find so
attractive
and i don't care what everybody else
thinks maybe
he'll be considered an ugly person but
to me he's my world but you said you
wouldn't marry an ugly man to you
i wouldn't i would somebody that i
consider ugly and it doesn't have to be
with physical looks it could be an ugly
attitude it could be the way he treats
his mom
or the way he treats a waitress and this
is what i was trying to say
sometimes if you meet somebody they're
not necessarily attractive to you at
first but
i think especially as women if you meet
a guy
right and this is how guys get out of
the friend zone all the time
if like you see him being kind to
someone if you see him demonstrating
qualities that make a good husband like
you might change your mind or somebody
else that's ugly to me it's like that's
when i said
ugly it's so subjective what is ugly to
you
and i can tell these guys aren't gonna
buy it but you know that's what i
yeah she gave that lawyer answer she she
deflected that like genji did
overwatch see and the guys aren't gonna
buy it but i know exactly what she's
talking about
um okay uh super chats real quick uh dvo
um maxo uh
short-term bang the attractive guy and
long-term married the rich guy
but what do you bring to the table
that's a very good one right now
we want to go we want to go around the
table with that one so okay
i'll add a caveat to that okay all right
so for example what do you bring to the
table
outside the sex say again okay
what do you mean you
to a man right you're taking serious
yeah
outside of sex what what do you think
she will bring besides
have you ever been in a relationship
that you obviously have sex but what
does she bring to the table besides that
tell me well i'm asking you to question
how it works
i have an answer but i'd like to know
yours okay well let's go on the panel
first and then we'll get back to your
question
for me yeah okay so i'm definitely
supportive
i'm definitely ambitious and i like to
be a part of
your idea so i can say comprehensive
yeah i got my emotions sometimes and i
want to stay in my opinion but in the
overall like i have really good
intentions i want to see you grow
um because if you grow i grow um
obviously good sex um great
communication
and i'm definitely adventurous so i'm
super down i'm open-minded i'm down so
i'm fun
and that's what i bring to the table
i feel like she just basically said
nothing okay
but we mentioned no sex okay no sex
besides no sex okay um yeah i'm
supportive
i'm ambitious i'm adventurous um i'm
definitely open-minded
you know to a lot of things so yeah i'm
a good time
cool time all right
i'm a good time like my answer is i
don't know
i don't know what i would bring to the
table if this is me you like it
you don't you know let's find out let's
figure it out together okay that's
i mean you're keeping it real i like
that at least being honest wait
you said you have a boyfriend though
right yeah i do well what would you do
for him then
oh a lot of things do you want to know
well i mean we literally just asked you
do you want to ask him i'm asking you
i mean you said i'm not sure what i
bring to the table and then i'm like
wait aren't you in relationship
honestly when i'm in my relationship i'm
not like what am i bringing to the table
is he happy if i do this i don't
question myself all the time i'm like
this is who i am maybe today but you
know something interesting
when you were asked what you're looking
for long term you had a laundry list of
stuff you mentioned
but then when you're asked what i just
had fun good sex and
somebody who would like these girls
do not understand the no sigh like you
can't say sex that's
that's what they said change with me
and we both like grow together okay so
let's say you brought four things but
then when you were asked what do you
bring to that person then you're like i
don't know
do you understand how there's like a
confusion there it's not it's not
confusing for me
they break they i swear they bring they
always bring the bimbos
on i'm not saying they're all bimbos
there's like 10 girls i doubt they're
all bimbos but
like i feel like they bring the girls
that would make the best
best click bait i know there's somebody
else that's not as confused
as you all right i'll confuse one i'll
take that
all right so i think i bring a lot to
the table i'm super motivated
like you just want to be my man you just
you need the support
system and i'm all about my man i
support him
i encourage him i motivate him i push
him i'm there for him i love him
i'm all about him as long as he's all
about
me okay so you cater to your man then
yeah
all right does that include if he wants
to have sex with other girls though
absolutely not you already know that
then in that case she does not support
you by a gentleman
in that case she does not support you
okay well for me
it's a best friend i bring in
perspective i teach them
um also with my current boyfriend for
example i'm teaching in spanish
but definitely a best friend somebody
that you can rely on that you can talk
to that you can play with that you can
just
feel like yourself with no armory
you know you can just relax and be
yourself
without the stress that goes on in the
world so no judgment
no judgment does like that there's a
type of unconditional love
does he wait you said unconditional love
there's a type of conditional love
because when it comes to friendship when
you have a friendship with someone
you love them for who they are laws and
all so you're telling me that your
relationship is unconditional love
as of now yeah i would say so okay all
right excellent all right
i believe that i am not a fan of this
guy
i do not like arrogant guys
and guys that try to like be
because he is i think he's the one
pressing these buttons and i just don't
like guys that are blatantly
disrespectful
although he could also not be the one
pressing the buttons but i just i don't
buy
that's a fallacy all love is conditional
especially on the female side but that's
okay
that's true love is conditional like
everyone has conditions
for me it would be cheating
like that's a condition or
you know just being like kind whatever
at some point yeah yeah
that's that's good if you're saying
definitely
out of your experiences then you're
telling your life definitely
because there exists unconditional love
i agree with her you
have unconditional love from your mother
you have unconditional love from a
brother
yes and it does exist and if you haven't
experienced it then you would say it
doesn't
that's that's that's happening i would
ask you if you're married to somebody
hypothetical right you know 10 years
from now you married somebody i have
three kids
he stops working he stops [ __ ] you
stops talking to you stops basically
being involved with you
and you would still love this man if you
kept that off i would still love them
but i would definitely
have to love myself more in order to
leave and let them figure out their life
because a lot of times women want men to
change
but you people don't realize that you
can't make people change
people have to go through their own
process and sometimes that process
requires them to hit rock bottom
so if that person needs to go through
their journey
and you not being there is part of that
and you do it out of love
then that is necessary and when that
person
so she's basically saying that her love
is conditional
um is there somewhere else i can like
um skip two
because i'm getting kind of bored here
annoying woman i think that's what
you've learned
in life seriously can you stop cutting
me off are you do you feel like i'm
cutting you out
i think this was like a conversation not
a monologue no no
did you not ask a question i'm sorry did
you not ask me a question
yeah i was asking you what is
unconditional love and then you cut me
off twice i counted it
are you yes i don't like his about she
probably did something
but um
and the motivation to a man and then
okay this is the next part i'm going to
react to
yeah it's very true um free smoke this
lady lives
okay hello yeah hold on we're going to
read that super chat oh you
want to read it yeah what was it 20
bucks though
oh okay um here's why yeah okay uh
rayon php 1250 what is that
i don't know what that country is i
don't know what that currency is okay
there's no such thing as unconditional
love even for a parent and child where
the condition is
that they're of the same blood what may
happen is that
the kind of love may change from being a
better half to a friendly one but it's
still conditional
okay uh and then we're caught up and we
are caught up uh how about we turn it to
you bro
y'all want to continue on this thread uh
it's up to you man you tell us
you know you can ask another question
then we'll turn it to the ladies ask us
something as well we'd like to not have
it be an interrogation type thing right
um so uh do you want them to go first or
do you want them to go first how are you
ladies can go first if y'all got
questions all right let's start
let's start with the couch then yeah uh
ladies on the couch will uh
yeah go ahead and ask us a question and
uh one of the guys on the phone
dating sex what you
[Music]
did it i don't know my brain doesn't
work okay so i actually have a question
for the men
yeah um i actually had a conversation
with someone one day
and they were telling me that women
bring the emotional support and the
motivation to a man and the man is
always the provider
do you believe in that statement yes or
no
honestly you you are actually right um
i'll say this as well
just for relationship purposes for guys
i feel like
guys are going to be the ones killing
the dragon bringing home you know i'm
saying to me
right making things happen but the woman
does support
um emotionally in terms of like if
things go wrong in the house
they take care of the kids it's kind of
like they have like a role to play and
so i still do men
but i feel like for men the main thing
is that you have your foundation set
you're not shaky you're like a rock and
she could depend on you to be the man
that you need to be
so okay i have a question now
[Music]
um how do you want to go next yeah i
agree with you that's why i didn't have
anything um
the only thing i disagree with is that
um men don't need women for motivation
as a matter of fact
it's if you have women as the motivation
you're going to fail um because
it needs to be an intrinsic sense of uh
motivation to become successful because
if you do it for women
that's fleeting well i didn't mean it in
like a way of
you know us being like the motivator for
you guys because already you
as men you should already have that
inside of you mm-hmm
but i meant it as in like family yeah
family
like if you were to build a family if
you were to build in that sense yeah
that in that sense yeah for the kids
like to be a good role model
yeah and in that sense we'll talk about
that too how a man really shows love
but yes um for sure like if you have a
family that's what's gonna
make you wake up at three in the morning
to go work overtime right you know what
i'm saying like there's no stronger
uh motivator than to provide for a
family for a man that's just
men are built to provide and that's
we're built for and it's very
interesting because that's why we asked
when you said oh well i
okay this hits home for me because when
i was like younger
i my if you guys go to my youtube
channel
i don't say this to brag i'm just saying
it as fact like this happened both my
parents
millionaires right my dad my whole life
worked like 12 plus hour days
and he would be gone for like months at
a time and for the longest time i felt
like
he didn't like love me whatever but
when i got older i realized like how
much more opportunity that i have now
and how much like more
like how grateful i am that he did that
because i have a lot of opportunity
and i don't have to worry about a lot of
things that i would have had to
otherwise growing up
so that really hits home for me because
when i got older i realized the way that
my dad showed how much he loved all of
us kids
was that he worked 12 hour days for like
20 30 years like
my dad's insane like literally that's
so i don't know just personal anecdote i
think they're right about that
i would support and i had to just you
know get the distinction do you mean
financially or do you mean
like so emotionally and you were like
well fine and sorry before i go
the other thing they talk about men
being on their purpose and that's
absolutely true because even outside
like i do know that like my whole life
my dad told
me and my siblings that like his goals
he wanted to pay for our college but
on top of that like
i know that my dad like is so into what
he's doing and on his purpose and like
doing something that he loves
that like even if we weren't here i know
that he would be
on his purpose if that makes sense
financials like well how long would that
last and you said well you know
for a period of time but i think that's
the fundamental difference between men
and women
men are comfortable supporting long-term
and provisioning we're built for that
women or not like yeah if you lose your
job
your girl will tolerate it for a little
bit but if she ends up paying all the
bills for like a year or two at some
point
she's gonna be out she's gone so
naturally do you feel like that's
like as a man like do you feel like
that's what you're here
not here for but naturally like that's
what's inside of you like you feel like
that's
men are better providers than women are
because we're built for it you know what
i'm saying like like a woman can do it
but she can't do it long term okay she's
a as
if if a woman provides for her man long
term it's inevitable that she's going to
lose attraction
what about this day and age do you feel
like it has changed
like the generational wise like how we
how
how we've changed into society like do
you feel like you're asking more than
one question but sorry
i will say i will say this yes things
have changed significantly
um but yeah it's it's it's not changed
for the better okay yeah if anything
it's hurt families
yep rosie you had some technically you
just answered it
okay sorry i'm sorry fair enough do you
remember your question yeah i do i
i was gonna ask how you would feel if
the woman was
like actually okay like providing for
you like providing for the family
and making some nick like significantly
more money than you um you know that
that sounds good on paper but
communism did too and that didn't know
for sure for sure but it does happen
though sometimes like with it
very rarely very rarely but i'm asking
you like how you would feel
yeah the man here honestly like in that
scenario
because i wouldn't even be there yeah do
you want to feel like you're the one
that is the one that is providing
because whoever pays sets the tone for
the uh relationship
yeah so they set the frame so as a guy
if my chick is taking care of me i don't
feel like a man
so you want to feel like you're the
dominant no no i don't it's more it's
more like example
i saw like a clip i don't know if it was
from this interview but or a different
one but i was talking to one of my guy
friends about it
and he told me that what men want to
feel is
needed and useful and he mentioned that
like
his wife and him were looking at houses
and then
when his wife liked a house and he like
told her that it wasn't a good house
because the bones were bad or whatever
and she just like trusted him and made
him feel like needed
that like he just felt so good about
himself and that was something that i've
never really like thought about because
for a long time i was very much like
independent whatever
i don't need like
okay i'm gonna retract that because
there's some girls that are way far to
that extreme
but like actually i i feel like i'm
really good on my own but sometimes like
letting a guy do things for you
is like it builds their self-esteem
and that's not a bad thing at all i like
to see in my
my life is going to be built off of like
my labor and my
foundation so i don't want to say hey
you know what my girl like yo
take your house because i can't do it if
i can do it i'm going to do it i'm going
to let her do it at all
yeah i had i completely understand that
but i was just like asking like
how someone or like as a man would feel
like if your
wife is inevitably making a lot more
money than you are
because i feel like that would like make
like if you're making a lot of money in
your life he's making a lot of money too
then like
here's the problem that works out here's
the real reason why
most folks listen i probably wouldn't
like it yeah
if you want to work that much and make
that much money that means you're not
going to be there
to raise the kids right and at the end
of the day me i really enjoy working i'm
really focused on what i do
i understand she makes more and i
respect that do your thing but you know
if you want a wife who's going to be at
home with the kids one of the parents
has to spend a lot of time there
someone's going to have to be on the
back burner when it comes to her
not if you get a nanny i grew up with
nannies
i'm good i'm fine i'd prefer to be my
wife so that's the only reason why i
wouldn't like it
if you could work two hours and make a
billion dollars and go go do your thing
i got no problem with that
but for me personally i would like
somebody to be at home with the kids
when i'm not able to be there yeah i was
just wondering
yeah that's hard
i'll just i'll just add my little point
in the reason why i don't like it is
because i know how women think
and the thing is is that the unfortunate
reality when it comes to dealing with
women is
a woman must respect you first before
anything and
for her to love you she's got to respect
you men don't necessarily operate
that way you guys love very differently
than what than how we do if you can have
a discussion about that later on
but the thing i understand is that for a
woman to love you she's got to respect
you first if a woman out earns you
or is higher than you on a socioeconomic
level or to some degree
i'm not saying it's always going to
happen but there's an increased
likelihood
that she's going to lose attraction for
you which then is going to turn into
loss of
arousal for you and then eventually
leave you
this is where i disagree a little bit
it's not always about money what matters
to me is that somebody's doing
something that they're passionate about
and moving forward in that profession
i've always said i would be willing to
date like a coach
who may not necessarily make a lot of
money
but he has dreams of like climbing the
ladder and making it to a d1 school
someday
maybe i make more money than him but if
he's doing something that he's
passionate about
and you know chasing after that dream
like
that's no big deal to me at least you
know what i'm saying
men are content with dating down women
are not a lot of the time
so understanding like these you know we
could say all the social constructs we
want of men and women are equal and i'm
a
boss babe and all this other stuff you
know my boy donald trump just commented
blow and i agree with him
times change instincts don't women human
beings are hardwired to be a certain way
for millions of years
and women are hardwired a certain way to
look for survival skills so
i'm not saying i wouldn't date a woman
that makes more money than me but what i
am saying is that i know
that more than likely that relationship
is going to fail of course
i just for example every girl we had on
the show that did that
only fans girls yeah strippers that took
care of their men we asked them are you
single now
yes yeah and they always broke it off
that was broken off always like they'll
say
i'll do it but what women say what they
do are two different things i don't mean
to be an [ __ ] but like it's
politically incorrect for a woman to say
i'm gonna leave a guy when he's when
he's broke so they'll make it work
to kind of like appease the masses or
they'll say that but every single time a
girl out earned her guy or she was
supporting him
would ask are you with him now and she'd
be like no i was like did you break it
off yeah i did
you know and then they'll say something
else oh he lost ambition blah blah blah
it's all a translation for
he couldn't provide anymore of course
yeah i'm just it's just coming from a
perspective of like
um someone who didn't have a male like
figure in their lives you know someone
that didn't have like that
that you know usually like the
traditional family has like
the man that earns and usually a lot of
women though
how old are you i'm 20 i'm 21. but a lot
of people you got mad time
no no i'm just i'm just asking because i
get what you're saying
it's just like for a lot of these you
guys are gonna see it's gonna change a
lot from when you're 21 to 31 and you
could probably chime in on this
what you wanted when you were much
younger your views are completely
different
yes that's absolutely true yes
you become a lot less materialistic
the older you get like
you're i don't want to say your
standards lower but your standards
become a lot more practical
where before like you might have wanted
like a certain height a certain like
like look whatever it starts to become
like
you care a lot more about like the
person like do you have common interests
common goals common values
can't wait to talk
these nervousness just give yourself
some time you're going to see why your
standards are going to change
no of course wendy can we go we got a
big panel right now
yeah yeah yeah we'll get we'll keep
going what's your question so my
question
um actually i'm very curious because
previously you've mentioned that one
percent of men which is what most women
want
um they need to be comfortable sharing
men
right and um we've been watching the
show oh i've been watching this show i'm
not gonna come unprepared and get kicked
out but
here we go for sure uh i'm actually i'm
open-minded i'm super open-minded but i
want to know a little bit more about
what that lifestyle looks like to you
what are the terms like
i i just wanna like you and your life
here
you're one percent of the men and your
women have to get comfortable sharing so
what does that lifestyle look
what do you expect women to react like
and how would you handle that situation
um i'm very very very curious are you
asking me in particular or i'm asking
each and every one of you in particular
yes
and then maybe we can end it off with
general come on man
are you ready no no i i just um okay so
for the women here that might not know
what i'm what she's speaking about
basically i said all the time on the
podcast
um if you're a higher status guy women
have to get content with they have to
accept the reality that you
they're gonna have to share you sexually
and when i sexually versus a
relationship are two different things
because
men can be detached from sex but women
really can't i mean some can
but on a balance of probabilities most
girls
tie emotion to sex to some degree
they're they're attached to some to some
degree men don't have that problem
so um as a higher status guy um what i
always say for
to women is except that you you're
probably gonna have to share them and
that
just be happy that uh he's taking care
of you because i always say men show
love differently than women do and the
way menstrual love is through
providing you resources waking up early
in the morning support you and the kids
like the other young lady was talk we
were speaking about
and taking care of you from a financial
standpoint when a man is investing his
money into you
that's when you know he cares but um if
he's smashing of the chicks that ain't
that big a deal
when he starts sharing resources with
other women that's when you need to get
started getting worried
it's interesting to hear like young guys
talk about
how that's okay because i grew up
with like like my dad's like a
multi-millionaire whatever
like and he ne he was so
invested in like what he was doing like
my dad doesn't even
drink like he's he doesn't go to bars he
thinks all that stuff's stupid
maybe he's a one in a million i don't
know a lot of you guys seem to think he
lives a double
life but like
it's just funny to me that like the
mindset
is that if a guy makes a lot of money he
has a right to cheat because i
absolutely do not think
that he does but you know teach his own
you know so um yeah so i i and again
this does not apply to all men
i'm just saying the higher status men
your celebrities your athletes here
uh you know media professionals guys
high earning men that a lot of women
like you know attractive guys tall guys
models whatever it may be
you're going to have to get consent with
that reality that all the women are
chasing that guy
and the uncomfortable truth that um
uh high status men are very rare but
beauty is very common
you know i seem to in the western
countries uh you know we seem to
pedestalize women and tell them
you know they're perfect the way they
are and everything else like that but
the uncomfortable reality is
as feminism has gotten stronger what's
happened is you've allowed women to
basically
have uniform um control over who gets to
mate
and if you leave women to their own
devices they're always going to pick
the top 10 of men etc they're always
going to pick the best guys right
so the best guys what the feminism
inadvertently did was they gave leverage
to all the higher status men and now
they're
having you know their fun while the guys
at the bottom are getting scrapped so
what i tell the ladies is just be
understand that this comes with the
territory you want to deal with a drake
a future a rapper an athlete whatever it
is
you're going to have to share them your
goal is to make sure that you're the one
getting the resources from that guy okay
and not necessarily caring about the
sexual access as much
would you be honest about it like me
personally yeah
yeah i am do you think most people that
have that lifestyle are honest about it
no a lot of guys lie
okay which is why like when i say this
it sounds like chinese to so many women
because like they'll be dating one of
these guys yeah and they'll tell them oh
no i love you blah blah blah like a lot
of guys will lie to women
to get in their heads uh but no i mean i
think that's messed up you should you
should
be honest with the woman about it you
know what i'm saying but a lot of guys
don't want to lose that sexual access
and they know a lot of women won't
accept it
i understand so they lie
for me personally i don't want to be in
a scenario because
if i'm single i'm going to do what i
want okay with somebody then
for me that's like okay i'm done playing
playing around like i just want to be
with one person
but once again just having the option of
being in one percent
am i gonna be tempted yes um what i want
to follow through
who knows but just having that access to
options makes me think you know what
i could be single forever because at
this point i'm not ready to settle down
so you know
i like that answer okay um
wait would you be honest about it yeah
no no if if you fall into the temptation
and
like i saw every girl like i talked to
her like for example like i'm just i'm
just doing me
like if you connect on that level and we
get to that point maybe but right now
i'm just doing me
and so let's say you you said okay i'm
just doing me and then one day you fall
into the no i'm sorry one day you say
i'm not i'm ready to settle down girl i
love you whatever but you fall into that
you're not talking to them
so let's say one day you say okay well
i'm committed to you i'm already done
with that type of lifestyle
um but then one day you fall into the
temptation
would you be honest about it especially
with you know
that viewpoint of hey i'm one person you
gotta be good with it
would you be honest about it me
personally i would just tell the girl
like
you don't gotta say it she's gonna know
yeah like like women know like you guys
can smell it when a man is getting women
you guys can just tell
there's certain there's certain
behaviors that men that are good with
women exhibit you know what i'm saying
like they don't tolerate [ __ ] they
don't
like sit there and like let you talk
[ __ ] to them or whatever it is like they
just
there's just certain unmistakable traits
that men that are good women have me
personally know i just wouldn't be in
that situation
if i'm going to cheat because well when
does it change me for example like i
just personally would just be single if
i'm
if i'm going to do my thing like why am
i going to commit to one person
that's just my opinion though what's
your view does anybody have like a
problem
i feel like a lot of people want to turn
does anyone have a problem with the
whole idea of like
you got a man and he takes care of you
pays all the bills handles all the
business you can just stay home and
chill go on a yacht every now and then
if he loves me
then go ahead you go for it yeah he can
get some cyprus yeah
no not just not just that but like if he
loves me enough to
care for me and to provide for me then
i'll do all
i can for myself not only not just for
myself but for him
to have that like you know vice versa
i understand like where they're coming
from
but i just feel like people
okay don't don't clickbait that because
the way i look at it is you want to look
for people that are kind caring and
honest
and if you're not those things like
you're not the type of person i want to
be with
so it's just interesting that
people think that you have a right to
dishonesty at a certain income level i
mean
obviously the one guy said he'd be open
and honest like with his like wives
about it cool but
like to think that you have special
rights to treat people poorly just
because you have money like
i don't agree with that
so if you're not okay with it you're
you're not okay with it right oh no and
why
why are you not okay with it because if
you are looking for something
that i'm not giving you then we don't
have anything to talk about
i you should be content and fully happy
with me
and everything i have to give to you and
i know that maybe it's a two percent of
the 100
but there is men out there that will be
consent with that one woman that gives
them
everything they need in every way
that's true that's true not all men
cheat and i think it's really toxic to
just
go into something assuming that all men
are going to cheat on you if they get
the opportunity because that's not true
guess what that's the average guy that
you don't want not true
and i'm telling you this because i have
had like
guy friends where i've seen like girls
flirt with them at bars or whatever
because in college you see stuff
and some guys do end up cheating on
their girlfriend when they have the
chance
and other guys don't even with beautiful
girls so i just don't like the mindset
of acting like character isn't part of
it
and like men are succumbed to their like
natural needs
it's not the average sign no i'm telling
you most of them are
nine to five guys so no job okay so if
he wants to be loyal to you but he's an
average dude is that an issue
it's not an issue but he has to be
ambitious and he has to have that growth
mindset and
always striving for better i don't want
anybody other words
isn't good enough no it's good enough to
open the door but you better not stay
average
no no no no i want somebody who's
growing with me all the way up what does
that mean what does that mean growing
with you
growing with me like my mindset is okay
let's just say my example
i am creating a course right a four-week
course now but then maybe in in
three months it's gonna be an eight-week
course and i'm always going to try to
create more
and make more and i want a man with that
same mindset who he always wants more
he's just not concerned with a hundred
thousand a month or two hundred thousand
a month yes i said that two hundred
thousand a month
or a million a month it doesn't matter i
want a man who's continuously going with
me
and i couldn't wait to talk because i
don't think that if we make more
it should put you down or make you want
to look for another woman who works at
mcdonald's
i think that it should motivate you to
do better and make more
instead of go and look for one that
makes less let that woman
motivate you to be better and make even
more
so why leave if you can just be
motivated by the ambition as
women and just do better guys can we get
dr marco for
abba's face this is princess and this
video is wrong he has his other face
here's the thing once again um
i i ladies i love your concepts even you
with the unconditional love like i'm not
here to
put down your points or anything but
what i am saying
is that i live in a reality based world
and even though it sounds excellent on
paper that i make a hundred thousand
dollars a month
i need you to get motivated to make a
hundred thousand dollars a month the
fact of the matter is this
okay the uncomfortable truth if you're
making a hundred thousand dollars a
month you're not even gonna look at
average guy
he's not gonna be on your radar like you
can say that all day like yo i
i want to grow i want to grow with
women have thresholds as you become as a
woman this is uncomfortable truth i'm
going to tell all the ladies in this
room right now some of you are younger
some of you are older
as you make more money and your
socioeconomic uh
status changes for the better more doors
close
the men that you're competing with as
they make as you're competing for as
they make more money become more
successful
their doors open because men don't have
the constraint
of having to date either equal
socioeconomic status people
or higher like women do so as you become
more successful
it's almost going to be shackles on you
in the dating world so i'm not
saying that you can't grow with someone
but i live in a fact-based world and i
know
the more status of money a woman makes
she's not going to look at an average
guy
there's a reason why you know there's
some very attractive women here in the
panel i'm sure you guys
i'd like to say jeff bezos's ex-wife
married a teacher
i'm just saying probably party with
rappers celebrities maybe we've been
invited to some exclusive parties
whatever
we don't get that privilege at 21. nope
you know what i'm saying rihanna's not
going to invite me hey you want to come
back to the trailer
like nah you know i'm saying she won't
even give me an umbrella you know what
i'm saying so
real talk so it's just completely
different
the the accesses and privileges that
women have compared to men
so i get weird to some women some women
i was never never invited to cool
parties
ever i i'm happy for the girls that got
that
but coming from that sounds great on
paper but that's just not the way the
world works it's not only on paper and
maybe it's the two percent of the man
but
you girls you will find that two percent
that loves you unconditionally and that
will grow with you until you're 120
years old it doesn't matter it's only
there
if you find an unconditional guy ladies
if you want a guy that's going to love
you
unconditionally and uh be faithful to
you yes an average man will do it what's
wrong with an average man
okay okay i want to know your answer
[Music]
i don't think there's anything wrong
with an average guy again
i've always said as long as you're
growing in what you're doing like that's
what's important to me guys
would you like as i said like you could
be
a coach which doesn't make a lot of
money as long as you're like
working hard and doing well i don't know
if that makes sense
like or even if you just do the nine to
five and get better every day like
that's fine so you won't settle right
no okay
do you do go ahead
say what you gotta say okay do you think
we're doing a good job with marriage
nowadays and
and dating in general do you think
people are finding what they want in
life no
no okay okay so i'm gonna see if there's
any other parts i want to skip to
again this is kind of long so i'm not
gonna watch this whole thing
okay so i'm at 59.
okay at home she gave you all you wanted
would you still be
out here in these streets i don't know
about that i'm not gonna say anything
for me personally what i'm trying to say
is a lot of men who are in that
circumstances
well actually i did ask the question you
didn't answer it so you had to answer
that question are you that one percent
here's the thing i'm gonna i can easily
say no right now okay
but i would not know how i would go
later on what i'm gonna say right now is
that for me
i don't even enjoy being in the streets
right now like i don't even enjoy
variety
and you maybe you can understand this at
some point it gets like a lot to be out
there trying to talk to you no it is bro
i'm so busy with work i can't be
bothered for a lot of that stuff
but i'm not gonna sit here and say i
don't understand why dudes do it i'm not
gonna say
here say you know 20 years from now i'm
going to feel the same i'm not that
arrogant what i am saying however is
if he takes care of everything and he
handles it and you're okay with
all that the agreement then what's the
issue right it has to be an agreement
i gotta ask i gotta be the contrarian
here what's up martin all right all
right
what was that chris uh the chat wants it
can't store analogy
okay no no no um well before i do it
going to the candy store analogy my
question is this
you mentioned you're giving a man
everything he wants can you tell me what
a man wants
oh no i can't i mean i kevin samuel says
fit feminine friendly right i don't know
what every man wants like
that's the problem that right there guys
is the fundamental problem
women don't really know what men want
they think they're giving him what he
wants but they really have no clue
and and then they wonder hey well what
the hell like
i'm giving you everything i would want i
make money
i'm successful i'm strong i'm
independent but the problem is that like
i said i always say this women think
attraction is symmetrical it's not it's
asymmetrical
the things you look for in a man are not
the same things a man looks for in a
woman
and one of the biggest things that women
can't grasp is that men like sexual
variety women
okay he likes sexual variety men treat
like men look at women i'd say like this
as sex objects they like that variety
like different colors shapes sizes
there's a reason why you look at music
videos
they have women of different colors
races
skin colors everything men like variety
just that most men will never admit this
because it's considered misogynistic
crass rude
and disrespectful towards women so they
will not admit this to you and they're
going to lie and say oh no i'll be a
monogamous with you whatever
once a woman understands that listen
my guy is probably going to run around
and deal with other girls and accept it
right and just understand that as long
as i'm the number one chick i'm cool
with it
then it is what it is but this another
alarming thing that you mentioned it's
not really alarming but it's an
it's a uncomfortable but there's a lot
of like
i don't know how to describe it but
there's just like different types
of like rich guys and half like the
rich guys that like my me and my family
associate with
i'm not saying they don't cheat because
you never know what goes on what you
never know what goes on behind closed
doors
but there hasn't been as much cheating
because like these guys are so
focused on what they're doing like my
daddy's never done anything like that
like and same with like
the people that we associate ourselves
with well truth is that
if you are equal to your girl and you
guys split the bills or whatever
she's going to tolerate far less from
you but if you're providing the security
and the resources
she will 100 accept you and your
lifestyle and other women that's why we
say
women are are okay with sharing high
value men they might not admit it on
camera they might not want to say it out
loud
but behind closed doors if the guy's
handling business and taking care of or
whatever
she will be okay with sharing him
sexually it's just that a lot of guys
cheat and don't take care of business at
home and that's when we get angry
let alone of a woman supporting a man
financially any cheats on her that's
what she's really pissed
and we know a couple girls like that
they're married to a guy he's very
successful
he's got all the bills and she knows
what he's doing when he goes on trips
but she doesn't want to see on her face
but she understands from the very
beginning hey honey you go through your
trip
i know what's going to happen i don't
want to see it but i understand and
she's happy because once again
she has the car she wants life she wants
kids are good so she understands
what it really is but can money buy
happiness that just doesn't seem like a
happy marriage
like
if that's what you want to do from the
money's worth it to you but
that's an agreement that she agreed to
you don't have to agree to that i'm just
saying if you want to
have a happy lifestyle with some of
these guys you may have to take down
that stuff and say you know what
okay this is what it is i'm cool with it
like what are you gonna buy another
house another car
like they say that after 85 thousand
dollars you're
how happy you are it doesn't increase
like the car your same car will get you
from point a to point b
but you want to tolerate like cheating
not the life i would sign up for so i
have a question so is cheating
okay because he maintains you oh okay
okay okay so
let's be very clear if you have an
understanding it's not cheating yeah
do you understand if we've agreed and we
said okay this is what it is that's not
cheating
that just means he's doing he's doing
what we're doing i agree if i agree to
it fine it's not cheating
how about if i don't agree with it well
then don't don't deal with him
so is it okay to cheat just because you
maintain me no just don't be with him
then no of course i won't but
yeah i'm asking yeah it is it's
absolutely okay
because the thing is i guess we're gonna
go into this huh oh god
it's okay if you're not an honest person
okay so i knew i didn't like his vibe
candy store analogy this is the only way
i guess that like uh
women can kind of understand it uh
let's do it okay all right so
a lot of women don't understand why men
want variety and everything else like
this so i'll just i'll just explain it
right so you guys can kind of see where
i'm coming from with this
so there's a candy store okay women are
allowed into the candy store 18 years
old so all you guys love you ladies on
the couch right you guys are young and
attractive right you're 21 and you're
21 too both you guys you guys are at
your peak right now so you guys are in
the candy store all of you ladies are in
the candy store as well you're allowed
at 18 years old
the men are not allowed in though
they're not allowed in until they're 35
years old have a hundred thousand
dollars saved up
and have been in the gym for five years
consistently right
so you go on a candy store you might
have fun at first right
you and your laffy taffy you're in your
starburst you figure out that the yellow
starburst is disgusting
yellow laffy taffy disgusting you like
the pink starburst whatever it is right
you start to develop taste you like to
figure out your aisles you know where
you're going to stay in the store
right but the guys they're outside
lurking just waiting to get that money
and
get in that [ __ ] candy store so 18
years passes
and the men are finally allowed in to
have saved up enough money have been in
the gym right
they run in and storm the candy store
right go nuts they're eating all the
candies that you guys were rejecting
the tootsie rolls and [ __ ] disgusting
candies laffy taffy candy corn they're
eating all that stuff you're like yo
what the hell is wrong with you bro
chill out
[ __ ] is wrong with you but what you
ladies don't understand
is that the men had to wait there for
almost 20 years to get into the candy
store
so for them just being in a candy store
and being able to finally get that
access of different flavors and
everything else
is it's amazing for them because they
they had to work to get it
and what women don't understand is that
i always say this privilege is invisible
to those that have it
okay so it's very difficult for women
some women
some women to understand the concept of
why men like to have sex with a lot of
girls because
you guys get sexual abundance at pretty
much
women are born with value ladies men men
have to create their value
so for us to get in that same candy
store we ultimately have to bring
something to the table
so if a man busts his ass for years
saves the money
gets in shape everything like that gets
in that candy store why do you think he
should only have one piece of candy
but i mean like but he doesn't have to
if he chooses if he makes the decision
to be in a relationship
either pick somebody that agrees to that
that's fine
or like or don't be in a relationship
you don't have to be in a relationship
with somebody
and this is where i think society's
going downhill because
we don't value things like honesty
integrity
and like being god-fearing the only
thing that he's valuing in his society
is money and if you don't believe in god
if you don't believe in the devil like
of course why would you follow it but
just my two cents who am i right
he's like who is that but like who made
i mean no i mean i guess if i were to
bust my ass i wouldn't want one piece of
candy either so
and that's the thing because women like
i say again i'm gonna say one more time
because i want you guys to understand
this privilege is invisible to those
that have
it you guys don't know the value that
you guys have because you are women you
live your life
you've you know you guys get accesses
and privileges that men will never get
like i said a bunch of you have probably
seen or party with athletes or
celebrities whatever get invited to
exclusive things
man man me i have a fresh way getting
invited to no boat parties no mansion
parties unless we know somebody
i've never i
i okay okay i think i get oh shoot i
don't know why i always try to move this
at the end
i think i understand the gist of what he
is saying
um i understand the concept i understand
why he thinks what he thinks
but again if you're somebody that values
honesty integrity being a good person
like it's different mindset
anyways let me know in the comments did
i get it right did i get it wrong either
way let me know
in the comments anyways um i'll talk to
you guys later bye